je crois que c'est qu'ils étaient en
fait nous le savons mais ça veut dire
que ce débat n'est pas là pour rien ça
veut dire que ce qu'a dit le président
de la république
il était temps de commencer à bouger et
ça veut dire que demain il faudra que
les municipalités qui pour l'instant
sont encore on peut convenir un peu
frileuse
après les municipales je pense que des
choses vont se passer je pense qu'il par
exemple quand le président de la
république parlant c'est un autre
domaine c'est peu près de la cité de
vigilance à l'égard de la radicalisation
mais là quand vous pensez que la charia
est supérieure aux lois de la république
vous êtes quand même pas loin de la
radicalisation carrément faut quand même
le signifier et je pense qu après les
élections municipales il faudra quand
même que les municipalités rentrer dans
l'addition passe quand vous parlez de la
société de vigilance qui sont les
premiers qui doivent être vigilants
c'est quand même les collectivités c'est
quand même les élus mais c'est quand
même ce qu'ils connaissent plus la
population et qui conserve le plus en
capacité de parler d'expliquer je pense
que nous ayons mal on le disait on en
parle pas beaucoup de ces choses là
or je pense qu'aujourd'hui bon c'est
pour ça que je suis pas critique sur ce
qu'a fait le président de la république
je tique sur beaucoup d'autres sujets
mais sur là-dessus non parce que je
pense que ça le mérite de commencer à
poser la question et à permettre demain
à des édiles à des mères à des adjoints
à des jeunes qui vont dans une salle de
sport de ne pas supporter comme par
exemple qu'on diffuse nenê des versets
du coran pendant qu'on fait de la boxe
et que ça permet aussi aux municipalités
de dire à bettié coûté si vous voulez
une subvention les gars c'est très
simple mais on va d'abord signé une
charte de la laïcité comme l'a fait
dévier b report mais je pense que ça
suffit pas mais on commence à dire le
droit
c'est un point d'appui c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui c'est ce que disait c'est
ce que disent
certains de mer ce que nous entendons et
georges fenech puisqu'on me fais
beaucoup de réunions avec eux c'est
qu'ils voudraient que ce soit l'écart
par exemple qui impose la charte de la
laïcité de façon à ce que quand ils
arrivent dans leur conseil municipal
il disait moi et quand on leur dit non
il faut pas se presser les choses comme
ça qu'il faut faire